[Music]
foreign
but those Smiles scream that love may be
in the air for Shawn Mendes and Sabrina
Carpenter enjoy yourself and do what you
do and don't try to be anything you're
not last week photog spotted the pair
sneaking out of Miley Cyrus's album
release party and now a source tells E.T
Sean and Sabrina are seeing each other
they've been hanging out a lot and
trying to keep things low-key Sean is
happy
they were both at the Vanity Fair Oscar
party Sunday night too but didn't take
any pics together
[Music]
it's been just over a year since Sean
channeled his heartbreak into song after
splitting from Camila Cabello in late
2021. a lot of the thing that also like
is resonating and the lyric for me is
like oh you don't realize
like when you're like breaking up with
someone you're like think it's the right
thing it's like you don't realize all
that comes after it language is like who
do I call when I'm like in a panic
attack who do I call and I'm like
Sean and Camila first started dating in
the summer of 2019 with things turning
serious during the pandemic they even
moved in together and talked engagement
I really think when you know you know
and
um she's been one of my best friends
since I was like 15 years old so I don't
know at the same time I know we're
really young so I don't want to jump
like insanely fast but
I think when you find your person you
feel and you know that you found your
person he's the best and I think we're
really supportive of each other
broke their breakup news in a joint
statement but made it clear their love
for one another as humans is stronger
than ever and look you have awesome
people in my life around that same time
Sabrina had an entanglement of her own
while she never confirmed it fans
believed her to be the girl Olivia
Rodrigo called out in her breakup Anthem
about Joshua Bassett and you're probably
with that blonde girl there was a big
news story that would not go away about
a song that may or may not be about you
how badly did you want to shout I would
like to be excluded from this narrative
um
I don't know I don't know if I ever
shouted those words
um I think if anything I was just
there's a lot of smiling and nodding
there was a lot of keeping it cute
um and a lot of uh saying please and
thank you and just understanding that
life is a journey and it's a roller
coaster and you never know what's gonna
be thrown at you and so that was like a
a really good example of that fast times
fast nights and up till now there had
been speculation Sean was seeing his
chiropractor Dr Jocelyn Miranda after
stepping out together a number of times
but our source says it has never been
romantic between them
foreign